so I'm very excited uh to introduce our
next keynote speaker uh KY wo who's been
a a longtime friend and a longtime
awesome member of the art community uh
and again I have a little
poem poem I'll put that in here qu
introduce
you meet Caro a data scientist Pro from
Insight RX where her coding skills glow
she crafts software with the greatest
Precision striving to better medicine's
tailored decision taming data is her
cherished Mission debugging pipelines a
twisted
rendition when test that cheers you rock
in Delight for her it's a win a
validation done
right with our ladies in our open sigh
she's in the mix teaching and workshops
sharing our fix passion for coding she
spreads near and far car wo ad data
Maestro a
star
thank you for that lovely poem
Hadley I am so excited to be here
talking to you all at positon today this
is the conference that I look forward to
all year long and every year I get so
excited seeing all of the amazing
projects that everyone is working on and
when we were F online in 2021 I got so
excited that I literally decorated my
office with streamers and balloons just
to capture that feeling of excitement
that I feel being
here positon feels like the club where
everyone is in on the cool things that R
can do and we're all here to Hype each
other up and for those of you who are
here more for the python content than
for our now that it is posit conf and
not our studio conf I'm sure that you
will have that experience as well
when I stroll through these conference
sessions and have conversations with all
of you in the halls I almost get this
feeling that I'm in this amazing
community garden where all of these
projects that people have lovingly
tended and cultivated are being shared
with the
community and that feeling is really
nourishing and meaningful I think
because when we go back to our
day-to-day lives and our jobs it doesn't
always feel that
way so I'd like to see a show of hands
of who has ever felt isolated or siloed
in their
work it's a lot of you and and I have
too when you go back to your day jobs
and your workplaces you may not have
colleagues to share a lot of ideas with
you might be self-taught in r or your
programming language of choice like many
others here and you might be struggling
to figure things out on your own
or you might face resistance from people
in your organization who say R can't do
that R is not good for that R is not a
real programming
language and it can be sort of jarring
to go from environments like this
conference where you can see all of the
amazing things that R can do to being
told that no it
can't so I have been there before too
and I have also been the stubborn person
at an organization insisting on using
because I knew that I could be
productive and build what I needed to
build with
it and having come out on the other side
of that experience I can say
definitively that I was
right not only is it possible to build
quality software in R I think everyone
at this conference knows
that it is possible to have an
organization where the strengths of R
and the people who use R can be brought
to bear to influence the entire
organization and its Mission as a whole
so I work at a company called insid RX
and inside RX I think is fairly unique
in how pervasive our is to all of what
we do so what I'd like to share with you
today are the ways that we are doing
this how we're using R not only in
production but as a first class language
that is essential to fulfilling our
mission and to illustrate how we're
doing that I'd like to introduce you to
Angela so Angela is a 60-year-old
patient with a prosthetic heart valve
and she comes into her doctor's office
one day complaining of having fevers
kind of off and on over the last week
she's just not been feeling very well
and her doctor draws some blood samples
and sends them off to the lab but in the
meantime Angela is getting sicker and
sicker and she gets admitted to the
hospital where it turns out that she has
contracted an infection called
MRSA so if you've heard of MRSA before
it has likely been in these kind of like
fled scary tones um and that is because
MRSA is very difficult to treat because
it's very resistant to many antibiotics
and so it carries with it this Spectre
of antibiotic resistant Super Bug
scariness but there are antibiotics that
can treat MRSA and one of the ones that
is used is called
vomisin so Vancomycin can treat Mera but
Venoy is very difficult to prescribe
it's very difficult to to get the right
dose for a patient and that is
because with fomy there is a very narrow
window between what is enough to treat
the infection but not so much as to
cause negative side effects and
particularly kidney damage so you need
to give enough that the infection is is
treated but if you go too high the
patient can experience kidney damage and
this is in contrast to you know some
other antibiotics like let's say an
amoxy Cy where you might have a lot more
leeway in how much you can
prescribe for Venom that window is very
narrow and not only is it very narrow
it's different for every person right
when you think about all of the
diversity in people who might receive
antibiotics which is most
people there's so much variation in
physiological characteristics and all
sorts of factors that can affect how
that drug is going to behave in a
particular person's body
and so there's no one dose that is going
to work for everyone Angela may be
represented by one of these bars on this
plot but a dose that works for her is
maybe not going to work for me or for
you so what we do at inside RX is try to
find the exact right dosage of
medications like fomy for every
individual patient and we do this by
combining peer-reviewed published
pharmacological models from the
literature along with the patients
unique characteristics and their data
their lab results to find the dose that
is going to thread that needle and fit
right within that window of enough to
treat whatever condition they're facing
but not so much as to cause negative
side
effects and so to do this we have a web
application that can access a lot of the
patients data either having it directly
inputed by their clinician or brought in
through their electronic health record
and so we get their height and weight
their lab results past doses that
they've received and we send all of that
data to a rest API that's written in r
that can Wrangle that data apply these
models and identify a dose that is going
to get that patient to their target
level of drug exposure so the the goal
level of amount of drug in their system
to treat the condition that they're
facing
and our rest API that's written in R is
going to send that dose along with
various other information and plots and
so forth back to the web application
where it is then displayed to the
patient's clinician and they can use
that in combination with their own
expert judgment to figure out how best
to treat their
patients so R is core to this product
because the entire point of its
existence is to recommend these Doses
and R is handling these most important
calculations to do
that and so because R is core to the
product that makes R core to fulfilling
our mission which goes beyond treating
individual patients but really towards
elevating therapies for all
patients and so at the next level we
have hospitals who want to understand
how their patients are doing as a whole
right are all of their patients reaching
the targets that they want to achieve
are they having rates of side effects
that are too high Are there specific
subpopulations that are experiencing
Better or Worse outcomes than others and
so we want to help them answer all of
these questions and we can do so using
data that comes from our Nova
application the one that I just
described so we have an ETL pipeline
that extracts data from the Nova
database it de identifies it transforms
it and wrangles it in various ways and
loads it into our data warehouse and
once it's in our data warehouse we've
then developed a second R pipeline that
pulls in the latest data batch processes
it to calculate these metrics that the
hospitals are interested in and loads it
back into the data warehouse so we've
written a custom r package that can find
the latest data calculate all the things
that we need to calculate and save it
back to the datab base where it is then
shown through dashboards and reports to
the hospitals in our inside RX Apollo
product so we have Nova we have Apollo
and then once we have this batch
processed data in our data warehouse we
can actually use it to refine the models
that power
Nova I mentioned that these models are
published and peer-reviewed models from
the
literature well in our data warehouse we
have access to in many cases larger and
more diverse data sets than the original
study authors had access to and so we
can in certain cases refine and retrain
some of these models develop new
models and create other research that we
feed back into the research Community as
well as bringing it back into the
platform and this is maybe our most
traditional use of R right because it's
doing analyses creating figures for
Publications writing reports but it's no
less crucial to the functioning of what
we
do so our R is a part of this entire
process of treating individual patients
and improving then care for all
patients we have our rest API that's
powering Nova we have our data
processing pipeline we have our analyses
and new models and we use R for many
other things besides so I'll I'll give
just a couple more brief examples to
give you a sense of the breadth of the
ways that we're using
R we validate all of our models using R
so we have implemented these models from
the literature in R and we need to make
sure that our implementations match what
was originally
published and so we've developed an our
package that can take outputs from our
models and compare it to a gold standard
in pharmacometric software and make sure
that those outputs all line
up for regulatory reporting purposes we
need to verify that our software behaves
the way that we say that it does not
just the models but the software as a
whole and so we have another r package
that can automate some of that
process and then we use R and
particularly shiny heavily for new
product prototypes So within the data
science team we have both a lot of
domain expertise as well as the coding
ability to be able to create product
prototypes for new ideas that we want to
explore and we can very rapidly develop
these prototypes much more so than if we
were going back and forth between you
know one team with the domain knowledge
and one team with the coding expertise
and there are many more options but I
will re myself in at that point but
suffice it to say that R is crucial to
all of what we are
doing but I don't think it's a surprise
to people here that R can do all of
these things individually right we know
that you can create rest apis really
easily with plumber we know that R is
great for writing analyses and creating
reports in our markdown or quto and we
definitely know that shiny makes it
incredibly easy to create awesome
interactive web
applications what is different here is
the attitude of r as a first class
language and the idea that if we have a
new problem we can and are willing to
solve it in R just as easily as we might
in any other
language and I think that that mindset
requires us to approach our work in a
fundamentally collaborative way because
all of our systems that I showed in that
graph have components that are written
in R and written in other languages that
need to work
together so when we're developing a new
feature there might be business logic in
our our API as well as UI changes that
are needed to support that feature and
so in order to make all of this work we
have to work very closely we're
following the same release Cycles the
same sprint cycles and adopting many
shared practices so that all of our
pieces of this system work together in
cont
concert and so as a result because our
work is so tied together when we have a
new problem we can be pretty open-minded
about who solves that problem and how we
solve it and I think that that leads to
better Solutions overall and so I'll
give an
example our Nova application is used in
multiple different countries in the US
as well as in Europe and so it needs to
operate in multiple different
languages and the way that we manage
this which is the way that many web
applic do is through localization files
so localization files list out all of
the pieces of text that might appear on
the
page and when the app is running in the
US it goes into the English version of
the file and pulls out the text that it
needs to display and puts it on the page
so at the change my password button it's
going to extract that text and put it
onto the page and if the app is running
in a German speaking country then it
will go to the German version of the
file and pull out that text and display
it on the page
and before every release these files are
professionally reviewed by fluent
speakers humans um but in between
releases we need a way to keep all of
these localization files up to date and
the way that we used to do this was that
anytime an engineer made a change that
affected some text they would edit the
English version of the file and then
they'd copy their new text into Google
translate and translate it into all
these different languages and then copy
and paste it back into the other
language files and this was very
cumbersome and tedious particularly if
you're changing 10 or more labels right
you have to translate all of these into
multiple
languages and so my colleague and I
decided that we could write an r package
that could make this
easier so our r
package will look at the English version
of the file and detect lines that have
changed text that has changed and it's
going to send each of those updated
labels to a translation API to translate
it into the multiple languages and then
it can go to the corresponding local
files and insert that text exactly in
the right location where it needs to
be and so now an engineer doesn't need
to manually run all of these
translations they can edit the English
version of the file and have the rest of
the translations automatically generated
for them and again before release these
are all reviewed but this speeds up the
development process considerably and
really reduces
friction and I think that this story
illustrates how R can be brought in to
solve problems that don't have that much
to do with data science right because
these are localization files for a web
application that is not primarily
written in R it's not primarily
developed by data scientists but we saw
this problem and this point of friction
and because we had this mindset we
realized that there was no reason that
we couldn't use R to solve it and in
fact we solved it very quickly and
easily using
R so our mindset of r as a first class
language empowers us to solve problems
we felt empowered to solve this problem
even though it wasn't primarily a data
science problem because we know that R
is a first class language at inside
RX and sometimes the problems that we're
solving may be relatively
straightforward things like making it
easier to work with localization files
but they can also be bigger things that
really affect patient care for patients
like
Angela so let's check back in with
Angela Angela is in the hospital she's
receiving vanoy to treat her MRSA
infection and as I mentioned with MRSA
and with
vanoy if the dose is too high it can
cause damage to the patient's
kidneys and so her doctors are regularly
collect cting lab results to make sure
that Angelus kidneys are functioning
correctly
healthfully and we're using those lab
results in our calculations to determine
what dose to recommend for
Angela but we realized that wouldn't it
be nice if we could actually alert the
clinicians in the event that Angela's
kidneys are starting to show signs of
acute kidney injury so we have this lab
data in the web application and we could
raise some warning in the UI to let the
clinician know hey you know there may be
a problem here maybe they need to adjust
treatment or take some
action so because we have this mindset
of r as a first class language we know
that we can do this in
R so we start with this idea for this
new feature and the mindset that we can
build it in R and then maybe we write
some code to detect acute kidney injury
and get something that works on our
machine but then to go from that to an
actual feature and a final product takes
a little bit more work and how do we get
from something that works on our machine
to that final
product we have had to invest in certain
practices in that space between the
Prototype and the final product to make
sure that our work is reliable and
Deployable so the reliability is
important for many reasons the most
obvious of which being that there are
real human patients whose health is
directly affected by what we're
doing and the deployability is important
because we need a way to make sure that
our code and everything that it needs to
run can get to wherever it's going to
run and even for software that's not
going to run in its own you know
Standalone way but rather things like
reports that we generate it's beneficial
to us to have a reproducible pipeline to
create those so that we're not subject
to the unique setup of one person's
laptop so when we're thinking about
reliability and how to detect kidney
injury reliably we need to make sure
that we're detecting it accurately all
of the
time and the way to detect acute kidney
injury or Aki is relatively
straightforward so in everyone's blood
there's a waste product called
creatinin and a healthy functioning
kidney is going to filter out creatinin
over time so ideally my body is
producing creatinin my kidneys are
filtering it out and that level is
staying relatively stable in my blood
but if my kidneys are not functioning
well then the level of creatinin is
going to build up and build up in my
blood and so if that level goes up by a
certain amount within a certain period
of time then that constitutes an acute
kidney injury and so if this were a
graph of someone's creatinin
measurements they start to go up and by
the time you reach the the dot with a
one on it the yellow dot that's a stage
one acute kidney injury and then there's
additional grades of severity beyond
that so elevated creatinin suggests
kidney damage this is relatively easy to
calculate in theory but in reality
things always get messy you might have
gaps in your data so that you can't
really tell how quickly creatinine is
changing you might have data that comes
in out of order that you need to sort
before you can
calculate you might have data that's
reported in different units that are
totally different and need to be
standardized you might be missing the
Baseline creatinin values for a given
patient so you know what their creatinin
is now but if you don't know where they
started then how can you tell how much
that's gone
up you might have data that's not
numeric I think anyone who has worked
with real world data has experienced the
phenomenon of data that really ought to
be numbers coming in with other
characters that you have to strip out
before you can handle it
appropriately and there might be data
entry errors either from the electronic
health record system or from manually
inputting
data and so when we're trying to build a
reliable feature we need to be able to
handle all of these scenarios both now
and in the future as our code changes
and to do that we add tests
so this is a test using the test that
package which is in my like top five
most indispensable our R packages that I
cannot live without and in our test
we're going to lay out the scenario that
we want to capture to make sure that our
code behaves the way that we expect so
this is a test where we say that we're
testing that Aki stage is calculated
correctly and we're going to run our Aki
stage calculation function with some
samp sample data that we expect should
produce a particular result in this case
it's a stage one acute kidney injury and
so then in the last line of the test
we'll explicitly state that we expect
that the result of our function is going
to equal a stage one kidney injury and
if it doesn't this test is going to
fail so we write these tests for all
sorts of scenarios that we want to
capture right different stages of akis
no Aki data that looks you know in
different ways
as well as scenarios that we don't
expect to encounter or hope we don't
encounter but would need to handle
gracefully nonetheless like out of order
data non-numeric inputs missing
observations and once we have this
collection of tests we are sort of
getting at all of our code from many
different angles to make sure that it is
reliable and it's functioning correctly
as long as we are running the tests
regularly right because if we're
changing our code and not rerunning the
tests then maybe we've changed some
behavior and we have no idea so we need
to run these tests often and if I am
disciplined I can do that 10 times a day
but I'm busy sometimes I'm lazy I have
other things that I would like to do
with my life other than run these tests
all the
time and the reality is that if we're
relying on me to run the tests they're
not going to run often
enough Jenny Brian once said that if you
use software that lacks automated tests
you are the
tests well if we build software that
lacks automated tests then that means
our users are the tests and by extension
they're patients and so that is not
acceptable at all and this is where
continuous integration comes in for
us continuous
integration allows us to automatically
run these tests so that we are
constantly making sure that our code is
behaving as intended so every time we
push new code to GitHub we kick off a
pipeline that gets that latest code it
builds the r package that it contains
and it runs the tests and then it's
going to send its results back to GitHub
in a way that we can clearly see so if
we were to look at the git history of
our project we might see something like
this we have a commit where we add our
function to detect akis and we write our
tests along with that so all those tests
are passing and we get this nice green
check mark which is very satisfying to
me and then maybe we realize that the
performance of our function is lacking
we need to refactor it in some way to
make it faster and so we rewrite it and
we think that we've preserved its
previous Behavior but actually we have
changed how it handles some Edge case
like how it deals with missing data and
so tests that used to pass start to fail
and our continuous integration pipeline
is going to send this angry Red X back
to
GitHub which I find incredibly
unsettling and impossible to
ignore so because I'm alerted in this
way that is very like pings me right in
the brain I can go in and fix the way
we're handling missing data in our
function so that the tests pass again
and I get my nice green check mark
back so continuous integration allows us
to find bugs quickly because it's
running automatically as soon as we make
changes to the code it lets us free up
time for more important work and it
makes sure that our code continues to
behave as we
intended so testing and continuous
integration together are two of the
practices that are most important for us
to ensure the reliability of our work
and then when it comes to
deployability we need a way to take our
code and all of the things it needs to
run and get it to some place where it
can run off of our laptops and there are
many different ways to do this if you
have access to posit connect that can
make it super easy um in our case we use
Docker heavily to be able to deploy our
applications so Docker allows you to
package up your code and everything it
needs to run into a self-contained
little bundle called an image so R
itself any R packages you need your code
any files your code needs all get
wrapped up into this nice little bundle
that can then be sent off to wherever it
needs to
run and we Define these Docker images
using a Docker file and so I'll give a
brief example of how this might
look in our first line of our Docker
file we're going to say that we're going
to start with an existing Docker image
that already comes with r and plumber
installed the r Studio plumber
v11.0 image comes with r and and plumber
and let's say we're building a Docker
image that's going to run a plumber API
so we need those that package installed
so we're going to take this existing
image and then we're going to add to it
whatever else we need so maybe we'll add
another package like this um open source
package called Clint PK that we
maintain and after we install our
packages we're going to copy over our
source code from our project into the
docker image so that's what this copy
line is doing it's copying over our code
and then we're going to set our working
directory to where we've copied that
code so we have all of our files nicely
around
us and then in the last line of this
Docker file we say that when we start up
a Docker container based on this image
we're going to Source this
entrypoint.sh those out but the
important thing about this is that
someone could build and run this Docker
image without ever installing r on their
machine you don't need to have R you
don't need to have plumber you can build
all of this and and run this project
without installing R yourself on your
machine and so that makes Docker a
really useful interface between our data
science team and other teams because
they don't need to know anything about R
to be able to build an RCT project and I
don't need to know all of the tools and
and background software for other
languages to be able to run those
projects and so when it comes to
deploying our application I go to our
devops engineer who maintains our
kubernetes cluster and I don't know
anything about maintaining a kubernetes
cluster and he doesn't need to know
about what it takes to run an our
project if I can share this working
Docker image then that can be that point
of connection and collaboration for us
and that has worked really quite well
for
us Docker is also actually an important
component of how we maintain the
reliability of our code as well so I
mentioned that our continuous
integration pipeline gets the latest
code builds the r package and runs the
tests but what it's actually doing is
building the docker image that contains
the r package and running the tests in
there and this distinction is important
because the docker image that it builds
is the exact one that we are going to
run in production it's exactly the the
same and so we can eliminate any errors
due to package version mismatches or
subtle things that are different in one
environment compared to another we are
testing the exact versions of everything
that's going to be deployed in
production and that gives us greater
confidence in that
reliability so we've built our feature
we've tested it those tests are running
automatically now we have our Docker
image that contains our feature and when
when it comes comes time to deploy the
final product we'll go to wherever we're
posting it and swap out the previous
version of our Docker image with the new
one that we've created and that gets us
to the final
product so we started with this idea
that we could build this feature and
build it in
R we wrote it we adopted these practices
to make sure that it was reliable and
Deployable and now not only Angela but
all patients can be monitored on an
ongoing basis and their medical teams
alerted
if they are experiencing acute kidney
injury so I've shared some of the more
technical aspects of how we make our
work in production for us and I am aware
that it might seem like a little bit of
a lot but for us these practices are
crucial to make sure that we can run our
inroduction and have it be a functioning
first class system within our
organization
and adopting these practices also gives
us as data scientists on our team a
greater connection to the rest of the
organization because we are all
following a shared set of practices and
and working together in a common way and
so we can bring our own skills and
practices that are useful to us as data
scientists to that equation as
well it's not just in the dashboards
that we create the visualizations and
the reports that we build that we bring
value to our
organizations we as data scientists can
bring our skills to the craft and the
process of building software as well and
that is something that I think a lot of
other people in our organizations can
learn a lot
from so what are these skills and
practices and and
mentalities the first one is that we as
data scientists are motivated to answer
questions I think that this is something
that unites most data
scientists and it's something that we
can apply to our programming conundrums
just as much as to modeling customer
turn or whatever it is that we're
doing debugging your code is essentially
an exercise in testing a hypothesis
Where You observe some phenomenon where
code that you have written is not
behaving the way you intended or is
showing some undesirable behavior and
you need to develop some kind of
hypothesis about why that is the case
gather some data that you can use in
some way to analyze and test that
hypothesis and maybe conduct some
experiment so I'll give an example of a
time where we did exactly
that in one of our applications that the
engineering team maintains we had a
database query that was too slow it was
taking too long to return data to a plot
customers were
complaining and so the idea was to add
an index to the database to make sure to
to improve the performance of this
query so we added this
index and then the next day our batch
processing pipeline that uses R to
calculate all these metrics that we show
to our hospitals in our Apollo product
that data processing pipeline was too
slow to
run and it was assumed that because we
had added this index that was slowing
down the pipeline and in theory this is
a plausible explanation because when you
add an index to a table typically it can
make it faster to read data but it can
make it slower to write data to that
table so we rolled back the change we
removed the
index and the next day our our
processing pipeline was fast
again but the day after that it was kind
of slow again so weird I don't know
whatever a few months later we had
another issue of a database query in a
different part of the app that was too
slow and again someone proposed adding
an index to the database
but this time the engineer who' had to
roll back that change last time said
well last time it slowed down this other
thing I don't think that we can add an
index
here so now we're stuck in a situation
where our users are suffering slow
queries but we are wary of making any
changes that would improve
them and I was not very happy with this
scenario because I feel like whenever
you're in a situation where you can't
make changes because you're afraid
breaking something that thing is already
incredibly
broken and we between our two teams have
control over this whole system so
there's no reason that we couldn't
actually figure out whether the index
was the cause of the slowness or
not no one had actually confirmed that
right they just rolled back the
change so together with a colleague of
mine we ran a little experiment we have
a staging database where we can test out
changes before we make them to
production so on that stting staging
database I ran our data processing
Pipeline and I timed it and then we
added the indexes that we wanted to add
and then I ran that same pipeline again
and timed it again and I think that they
were like within milliseconds of each
other like there was absolutely no
difference in how long it took to run
this Pipeline with and without the
indexes and so there was no reason that
we couldn't add those
indexes so I share this story because I
think it illustrates a time when we
could bring a data science mindset and
an experimental approach to solving an
engineering problem that would have been
really difficult to answer without some
controlled
experimentation the next skill that we
as data scientists I think bring to the
process of building software and and the
work that we do as a company is our
ability to visualize and communicate our
findings
a simple plot really does speak a
thousand words and I think that for a
lot of people who have been in data
science for a while it's almost second
nature and you can almost take for
granted right the ability to throw some
data into a plot just to answer a quick
question but it's really an empowering
skill there's all kinds of tools out
there for observability and monitoring
the health of software applications that
will'll show you all kinds of different
charts and graphs and whatever but when
you have your own data and just want to
see how it looks nothing beats the
ability to do that really quickly on
your own without having to feed it into
some external
tool so another example our devops
engineer came to me and asked if we
could compare two different ways of
Hosting our R API so we had it in one
hosting environment in AWS and because
it's AWS there's like a million other
options that you could consider to run
the same thing and so we wanted to
consider another one that could also
have hosted our our API but had
different technical limitations and
tradeoffs cost differences and
potentially performance differences
which was what we wanted to look
at so again approaching this like a data
scientist I ran another little
experiment and remember I talked about
the importance of adding tests well in
our code base we have hundreds of
examples of API calls that we use in our
tests to make sure that our code is
returning the results that we expect and
those tests then became the data that we
used for this experiment because when we
are comparing two versions of the API we
need some realistic test data that we
can send to those to time how long it
takes to return an answer and so all of
these test cases became the data that I
used and I sent them both to our two
versions of the API and I timed how long
it took to run each of
them and I plotted the results so on
this plot the x-axis is our existing
hosting environment and how long it took
to run each API call against that
environment so each of these dots is one
API call and on the y- axis we have the
second option that we were comparing it
to and how long it took to run against
there and you can see based on the fact
that all of these almost all of these
points fall below that one: one line
that option two was performing much
faster than option one or consistently
faster now to actually determine which
one we were going to go with of these
two options there's a lot more to dig
into right there's performance
underload you know there's configuration
tweaks that we could make to either
option to potentially improve things
there's the cost differences to consider
but as a quick answer to Is option two
worth pursuing this was immediate
yes and it took very very little time
and effort to create a plot that just
quickly captured that this was something
that we should
pursue so again we're bringing a data
science skill to an engineering decision
or in this case a devops decision in a
way that really helps us move forward
quickly and then lastly data scientists
are used to dealing with uncertainty
there is uncertainty inherent in all of
what we do and I don't just mean
statistical uncertainty although that is
part of it as
well I don't know if any of you remember
this website called
Twitter um but my colleague once tweeted
there that an underappreciated struggle
in data science is trying to not
sarcastically answer how many users did
we have last month with that depends on
what you mean by have users and last
month again I think this is relatable to
many of view that this struggle to
define the terms that we're even talking
about is an a crucial part of data
science I mean it might be like 80% of
data
science so data scientists are used to
digging into the weeds of this
uncertainty and when we are debugging
code it can really be like debugging on
hard mode because the types of issues
that we run into in many cases are
different than in more traditional
software a bug in a machine learning
model
may not translate to an obvious
error right it might just degrade the
accuracy of the model so how do you even
know if a bug is there right it takes a
lot of skill and dedication to uncover
these types of issues and that is work
that data scientists are used to putting
in because the nature of our work is
very
uncertain so I think that this leads us
to kind of pull at threads when we're
solving a problem that other people
might not consider and bring allows us
to bring a lot of creativity to solving
those
problems so I think all of these things
our motivation to answer questions our
skill at visualizing and communicating
results and our ability to handle
uncertainty are all really important and
useful skills that we bring as data
scientists to our organizations wherever
they may be and they're things that
other people can learn a lot from too
so I hope at this point that I have
convinced you that using R in this way
is working for us it's not always easy
sometimes it requires us to go outside
of our comfort zones pick up some new
skills but in my opinion the benefits
really outweigh the challenges because
by using R throughout our software stack
we're enabling ourselves to do science
throughout our software stack and that
is true both in what we build and in how
we build it so in the products that we
build we are taking advantage of ours
strengths to provide the best therapies
possible for patients and in how we
build it in the process of how we're
working we're taking on new practices
that improve our own work making it more
reliable and robust and we're sharing
our unique skills as data scientists
with others in the
organization so for those of you who
raised your hand when I asked if you had
ever felt isolated or siloed in your
work or if you're just looking for ways
to take the things that you're learning
about here at this conference back with
you I hope that I have planted a seed
that it is possible to do this it is
possible to bring the Bountiful ideas
that you are picking up with picking up
at this conference and share them with
your organizations and I hope that you
will
[Applause]
thanks Cara so hopefully you remembered
uh if you want to ask questions ask them
on slido uh while those Po and I have a
question for you Cara and that is you
talked a lot about using r at work yeah
do you have a fun example of like using
R outside of work at home to solve or
some kind of are outside of work at home
all the time for a while I haven't done
this recently but for a while I was
tracking my car's gas mileage with a
shiny app cuz I like I noticed when I
was like filling it my car up at the gas
station that it seemed like I wasn't
like getting as much mileage out of a
tank and so I would at standing at the
gas station while I was pumping gas like
put data in a Google sheet and then I
wrote this shiny app to visualize how my
gas mileage changed over time I do
household budgeting in r i feel like
there's other examples but yeah I use R
nice all the time
time okay hopefully Jenny Brian is
helping me out uh filtering the slider
question so hopefully she is about to
paste one in
here while it happens I'll say I I um I
use r a lot at home as well and we use
it like surprisingly a lot for this
conference like a lot of the information
ends up in a Google sheet which we can
collaboratively edit and we have like an
our markdown script or quarter script
that like pulls it and displays it in
various ways it's like such a great that
that combination of like Google Sheets
for data entry and R for like exploring
it's like such a powerful combo yeah
it's it's very empowering just to like
be able to do that okay Janny is typing
into slack right
now okay while cicd helps maintain
consistency how do you how do you think
about test coverage and how do you think
about like when Behavior or changes or
models update to the St the actual
stakeholders sorry can you say the last
part of that again uh how do you update
stakeholders when things change whether
that's like model uh model updates or
changes into Behavior yeah that's a
great question um so when in terms of
test coverage I mean there's a variety
of automated tools that can tell you
exactly how much test coverage you have
um and so those can be really useful and
but I think that for us a lot of it
comes down to the social expectations
and just amongst our team reinforcing
that when we're adding new code that
we're testing all aspects of that and so
like I'm being like kind of pushy in my
code reviews to make sure that we are
you know testing things as we're as
we're adding them um and and testing
multiple different scenarios so I think
that there's like a big social component
to that process and then when it comes
to updating
Behavior again I think with with how we
work because we're in the same sprint
Cycles we we kind of have a lot of
visibility across stakeholders as to
what new features are coming what
changes in Behavior are coming and in
many cases those also have to be
communicated to the customers as well
and so when we you know develop a new
feature we on the data science team
develop a new feature that turns into a
feature in in the application we might
write up some you know one-page
explanation of what this is what it
means you know how to interpret it that
we work together with our customer
success folks to turn into something
that can be user facing as well so um
there's there's a lot of kind of
translating and and communicating in in
written form as well yeah thanks what
about learning skills that are kind of
traditionally out outside the Wheelhouse
of a data scientist like how do you go
about learning docka and and other tools
like that great question I in my
experience I Peak at a lot of other
packages so I have various people on
GitHub who I know write good software or
write interesting tools and I want to
see how they do it and so a lot of what
I learn I sort of take from examples and
that's why I put that Docker example up
on GitHub so that there is something
existing that is relatively simple that
people can play around with if they want
so seeking out examples especially from
other programmers that you admire I
think is a great way to learn and some
of it is trial and error
and um some willingness to get your hand
dirty and just try things out it's nice
also if you have like a small project
that you can work on I think like
a uh like for example my gas mileage
shiny app was how I taught myself shiny
because I I needed a way to learn shiny
that was going to be fairly contained
and simple so I started with a small
project that I was interested in that
didn't have a huge amount of of stakes
behind it so that I could just focus on
the
learning along those lines are there
kind of any Technologies you've like
learned recently that you think have had
a really big payoff or like maybe it
been really challenging to learn but you
think we're
worthwhile um that's a good question
question at work lately I've been using
anible a lot to automate certain things
so um our batch processing pipeline that
I talked about gets like scheduled
through an anible job we've got an
anible an anible job to run certain
reports um that's something that our
devops person set up kind of for other
purposes and I was just like oh that
seems cool I'm going to like do you mind
if I just like write some other jobs to
do other things and he's pretty chill so
he was like yeah go for it um so that
has been that has been uh a pretty
interesting tool that I've been learning
more about recently yeah can you can you
share any tips for educating and
persuading people that you encounter who
like don't see r as like a first class
language or as a real
[Laughter]
language yes and no I think um I think
that my bigger tip is to try to ignore
them as much as possible um because yeah
thank you because it is it can be
and to a certain extent if it's possible
to block that out and do what you need
to do then it doesn't really matter what
they think but if they're the ones
controlling what you can do at your
organization obviously that's a little
bit tougher and I think that that that
maybe gets back a little bit to what
Elaine was talking about in her keynote
yesterday that if you can find a way to
demonstrate some value early on then
maybe you can kind of of reinforce and
push to get greater acceptance once
you've shown that are in fact can do all
these
things what's your experience uh when
hiring new folks to how to like onboard
them into this like mindset of like go
from not being not just a data scientist
but to learning a little bit about
devops like how do you do it how do you
find that people oh that's a great
question I haven't onboarded a lot of
people to this way of working so far um
but I guess I have a little bit and I
think that when you can demonstrate some
of these tools that make it really easy
like test that makes it really easy to
write test there are tools that exist
that make this work you know not just a
chore but something that is actually
fairly easy to do and so when you can
demonstrate that and show how much time
it can save I think that that kind of
can get people into understanding that
this is a way of working that has longer
term benefits as well as well yeah so I
guess this is kind of a question for me
like as you've worked with like folks
from other uh languages and you know
doing their own kind of Dev opsy things
are there things that you like you see
your colleagues using where you're like
oh wow I wish there was something like
that in
[Laughter]
our I'm not thinking of anything I mean
r has really good tools thanks
adly I'll see if I can think of
something but nothing's coming to mind
thanks I'll take that I'll take that as
a
compliment uh any tips for pitching
decision support models to senior
Business Leaders who often prefer to use
their experience SL gut feeling
instead I do not have experience with
that um for for whatever reason that's
that's not been a challenge that we've
run into at inside RX so I don't I don't
think that I can really speak to that
one
unfortunately okay and I think we've got
time for one last question so what does
your R data science data science team
look like like how many people are
involved in building the package doing
modeling versus like product prototyping
or or testing yeah great question
insiderx is a startup so people wear
lots of hats we have now one two three
so our the we're I'm on a team of five
uh I am the only person with the title
of data science engineer and then we
have a number of data
scientists and the breakdown can vary a
lot so it depends somewhat on what
people are interested in but typically
I'm not involved in the modeling almost
at all and the data scientists will be
um when it comes to developing
prototypes I think almost everyone has
been involved in that but depending on
the project it may not be everyone all
at once um I am mostly the person
responsible for maintaining the
continuous integration pipeline
you know maintaining our our Docker
build process um and developing new
features within our rap could be anyone
on the team I do it a fair amount but
other data scientists do as well great
well thank you so much
Cara